this lesson we're going to talk about
unit conversions so understanding how to
convert from one unit to another unit
using unit conversions is an important
concept to understand for the act and
what we're doing is we're going to go
through an example see if you can do
this one on your own we'll go through it
together
it says if a 20 inch diameter wheel okay
rotates at 50 revolutions per minute how
many feet does a point on the outer edge
of the wheel travel in one hour so let's
just draw a diagram here so here's the
wheel it's a 20 inch diameter wheel and
we're looking at a point on the outer
edge you know how far does it travel
okay um you know if it's rotating at 50
revolutions per minute
how far would it travel in one hour so
let's start with it with what they give
us which is the 50 revolutions
per one minute right
so every time this wheel goes once
around okay that's one revolution it
travels the circumference of the circle
and remember circumference is 2 pi r
or pi times diameter so in this case it
would be 20 pi inches so 20 pi inches
now you know you're on the right track
because the units that you don't want
are going to cancel out numerator and
denominator so now we're into inches but
we want to figure out how far is it
going to travel in one hour well
okay let's see we're trying to figure
out how many uh
feet does it travel so first thing let's
travel let's translate from inches to
feet so we know that there's 12 inches
in every one foot and i set it up this
way so that the inches will cancel with
the inches and we have feet okay and
we've got minutes so feet per minute but
we're trying to figure out how many feet
does it travel in one hour so we have to
convert the minutes now to hours so
there's for every 60 minutes there's one
hour oops one hr one hour so you can see
the minutes are cancelling numerator and
denominator and we're left with feet
per hour per means like divided by right
so number of feet divided by the number
of hours so now all we have to do is
multiply all the numerators together all
the denominators together and then
divide and that's going to be our end
result so i'm going to go ahead and do
that on the calculator just so we know
what the answer is it's 50
times 20 times pi which is 3.14 you can
use your pi key times 60 okay all
divided by 1 times 1 times 12 times 1
which is 12 so divided by 12 and that
comes out to
15 000 okay 15
707
well we'll round it to 708 so it's about
15 708 feet and you've got it so
basically unit conversions are all about
you know recognizing that you know
working with fractions the numerator and
denominator those units are going to
cancel and you're going to switch from
one unit to the next unit to the next
unit until you get the units that you
want so definitely an important concept
to understand i'll see you in the next
lesson